Speaker 1: There's something different about
The David Pakman Show as compared to many
of the shows you might see from corporate
media, which is that we are actually primarily
funded by our audience and we try to make
it really easy for our audience to support
us.
You can make a pledge on Patreon, you can
become a YouTube member, you can support us
on Twitch during livestreams, all these different
ways.
The best way, the simplest way, the most direct
way where we help keep the largest share of
every dollar that is contributed is through
our website memberships you can sign up at
join Packman com.
The perks are straightforward.
We do an extra show for all of our members
and you also get our daily show earlier and
commercial free.
And most recently you also get a soundboard
that mimics my soundboard album.
You know, at.
Speaker 2: Throat Central Pac-man's a.
Speaker 1: Loser.
We have a soundboard like that available to
our members.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
I look forward to welcoming you into the membership
ranks.
Well, folks, it's the Trump laptop.
Yeah, it's, you know, with all of these things,
it eventually comes back around and really
bites Republicans.
We are now aware of a laptop belonging to
a Trump aide that contains on it classified
documents.
I know, I know.
But what about Hunter Biden?
What about Hunter Biden?
This is really unbelievable.
CNN reports that the Trump team has turned
over additional classified records and a laptop
to federal prosecutors.
Wow.
The Trump attorneys also handed over an empty
folder marked classified evening briefing.
These are additional handovers.
Understand still related to what took place
in December and January.
And it suggests, CNN writes that the protracted
effort by the Justice Department to repossess
records from Trump's presidency may not be
done.
A Trump aide previously copied some pages
of these classified documents onto a thumb
drive and a laptop, not realizing they were
classified, according to sources.
The laptop, which belonged to an aide who
works for Save America PAC that's Trump's
scam pack and the thumb drive were also given
to investigators in January.
Special Counsel Jack Smith's investigation,
which is pursuing criminal charges, possible
criminal charges subpoenaed Trump last May.
For all of this stuff.
Folks, there's a laptop, okay?
It is not surprising necessarily, but in a
sense, it is still shocking that after year
after year in, year out, year in, year out,
Hillary's server, Hunter Biden's laptop, we
now discover that Trump had people working
for him involved in the mishandling of classified
information, which we knew already.
But now we even introduce a laptop element
into it.
We need that laptop.
We need that laptop and foremost.
Former federal prosecutor Shawn Wu was interviewed
by Jim Acosta on CNN recently.
He said that laptops got to be a part of this
investigation.
Listen to this.
Speaker 3: I turned over even more of these
classified materials.
A laptop has also come into the picture here
to federal prosecutors in recent months.
Speaker 4: It really underscores the enormous
difference between what's going on with Biden's
documents and Pence's first of all, volume
of documents.
But the fact that they're still finding more
and the fact this on the laptop is a huge
security concern for that.
So it really underscores why you really need
a criminal investigation of that.
Some questions in my mind still about why
the special counsel appointed for Biden and
how come still have one for pets.
Speaker 3: And the laptop is a concern because,
I mean, who knows why?
Speaker 4: Well, not only it's a concern that
was downloaded, any classified information,
sensitive information downloaded onto the
laptop from there, it's easily transmitted.
It could be copied to other electronic devices
as well.
So that's very different than if you could
say, hey, it's inside a room.
At least we know where the document the paper
document was.
But once it goes electronic.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, there's another element to this as well.
As I mentioned, the laptop belongs belonged
to someone who worked for the Save America
PAC.
Those aren't in in a sense, those aren't even
political arms in the operational sense.
We're talking about a PAC which just distributes
money that is raised and figures out ways
in Trump's case, to funnel that money back
into his friends and family and family members.
So that is not even someone in the universe
who of of people who even hypothetically should
be reading classified documents.
So the question we're quickly coming.
Two.
And I know many of you are frustrated and
you've been sending the emails.
When is Trump getting indicted, if at all?
And I continue to say, I don't have any idea.
You may all remember that for a period of
years I came to you and I was almost in tears,
quite frankly, saying Trump's not going to
be indicted.
I don't expect any indictment whatsoever.
And if he's indicted, he's not going to see
a day of jail time or prison time.
I admit that in the aftermath of the search
warrant being executed at Mar a Lago, my view
shifted as to the likelihood of an indictment.
And I thought, oh, an indictment seems more
likely at this point.
But I still maintain that Trump is not going
to see any jail time, any prison time.
Even in the most extreme hypothetical where
Trump is convicted and sentenced, it would
either be a suspended sentence or a sentence
to be lived out at his home.
And that is thinking so many years ahead.
Quite frankly, I am now going sort of back
to where I was previously.
I just don't know that an indictment is coming.
I really don't.
And ultimately, if either way, whatever consequences
there are are going to be minor and symbolic
in nature, does it even matter?
I do think it matters.
I actually think indicting a former president
would be a big, big deal.
It also could really throw the campaign into
further disarray, which would be great to
see.
And we'll talk about how that campaign is
going a little later.
But I share the frustration.
I don't know that an indictment is actually
coming at the same time Trump might be indicted
tomorrow.
It's extraordinarily unclear.
And in addition to that, there are so many
different investigations which could lead
to indict an indictment that it's very hard
to know what's going on.
I think the best approach is wait and see.
Live your life.
And if Trump's indicted, we will all know
and we will assess
from there.